indian farmers blocking roads in a
protest against new laws are refusing to
move to a government designated venue
thousands have been campaigning on major
highways near the capital new delhi
the farmers say they're open to talks
with the government as long as there are
no preconditions they say the new laws
will hurt crop prices
and their livelihoods the latest now
from elizabeth puranam
is at the protest site on the single
border crossing between the states
of delhi and haryana
[Music]
what's the latest there
hi adrian that's right we are at the
singu border crossing uh between haryana
and delhi and the numbers here are just
getting bigger and bigger with each
passing day delhi police estimate that
there are around
20 000 people here and they say that
there are even
more at another crossing between those
two states
and uh farmers and protesters are
blocking yet another
key highway coming into delhi and far
and those farmers are from the states of
uttar
pradesh um uttarakhand and they're
blocking the
ghaziabad highway now only a few hundred
farmers have actually moved
to the area that's been designated by
the government for protests and that's
because most farmers say
that that area is going to be an
open-air jail
and despite the government saying
yesterday that they are open to
immediate talks with the farmers about
these laws that the farmers are against
if they just clear the highways farmers
say that they would rather
continue to block these highways create
as much disruption as possible
until the government not just negotiates
with them about these laws because
that's happened they say that that
didn't go anywhere but until they
repeal laws which they say will remove
a minimum price for their produce
al jazeera's elizabeth reporting live
there
from the single border crossing many
thanks indeed to liz